bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7-8 sport
l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre émission
attentats de paris les rencontres
sportives de ce week-end dans le
département où tout était annulé
à saint quentin en yvelines la ligue
francilienne de handball avait décidé de
suspendre la rencontre de national une
féminine entre montigny-le-bretonneux
aulnay en football la rencontre du 7e
tour de la coupe de france entre
versailles le blanc-mesnil programmé au
stade mont boron a été dépassé à une
date ultérieure les détails dans cette
édition box élan pour toi marvin petit
sera sur le ring ce samedi contre
sylvain chapelle le match comptera pour
le championnat de france des poids
légers entretien / avec dans cette
édition avec le boxeur de la team
farruggia tennis de table championnat
départemental des vétérans était
organisée ce mercredi au complexe
sportif gilardi dicté sous bois plus
d'informations sur cette compétition de
ce magazine
et puis en fin d'émission nous parlerons
de la transat jacques vabre et du
versailles tanguy de lamotte qui a
terminé cinquième de la compétition
les stades d'ile-de-france est évident
ce week-end suite aux attentats de paris
qui ont fait 129 morts et des centaines
de blessés vendredi soir
de nombreuses rencontres programmées
samedi dimanche dans le département ont
été tout simplement annulé ou reporté à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la ligue
francs 6 l de handball avait décidé de
suspendre la rencontre de national une
féminine entre monty et bretonneau et au
nez de rosny sous bois de ce samedi
en basket la fédération française de la
discipline a décidé d'annuler les matchs
dans toute la france la rencontre entre
trappe et ormes au gymnase paul maye a
donc été reportée enfin en football la
rencontre du 7e tour de la coupe de
france entre versailles et le blanc mis
le programme est allemands bons à lui
était déplacé une date ultérieure non
communiquée pour le moment
une rencontre de coupe de france est
tout de même déroulée dans les yvelines
le match entre mantes le et le club
guyanais d'iracoubo a été maintenue la
partie s'est déroulée à huis clos dans
les installations de clairefontaine les
yvelinois l'ont emporté 4 buts à 0 grâce
à des buts de luxe massampu et dembélé
et guyanais ont également marqué contre
leur camp en fin de match mais tu verra
donc le huitième tour de cette coupe de
france
en revanche l'aventuré s'arrête pourquoi
si les pisciacais qui évolue en cfa se
sont inclinés à la surprise générale 1
but à 0 après prolongation à l'extérieur
sur le terrain du club réunionnais
d'excelsior club de dh et l'illinois
devront se reconcentrer rapidement sur
le championnat poissy à l'heure actuel
troisième de ces failles affronte ce
week end y ait toujours en football vous
le savez l'euro 2016 organisé en france
du 10 juin au 10 juillet 24 équipes
participeront à la compétition les
yvelines pourrait servir de camp de base
à 2 sélections nationales la france
résidera évidemment à clairefontaine et
une équipe étrangère pour s'installe à
versailles la cité royale a été retenue
par l'uefa le montage est signé et
xavier jamais une équipe nationale
pourrait prendre ses quartiers à
versailles pour l'euro de football 2016
l'uefa organisatrice du tournoi retenu
la cité royale pour accueillir une
sélection jean prochain la commune
yvelinoise est une habituée des grandes
compétitions
l'étudiant 98
du monde une équipe quitter la hollande
on a fait un accueil l'angleterre pour
le rugby pour la coupe du monde aussi de
2017 dans le dossier présenté à l'uefa
deux sites
on retrouve le stade mont boron d'une
capacité de 6000 places et l' hôtel du
trianon palace de versailles
notre terrain est quand même très
intéressant et il est de qualité il est
bien fermée quand on veut le faire mais
on peut accueillir du public tout un tas
d'atouts et puis la capacité hôtelière
de versailles est de qualité surtout sur
un dante équipements qu'elle trianon
donc l'uefa a qualifié le site autour de
ces deux aspects la qualité de notre
terrain et de notre équipement et la
capacité hôtelière pour accueillir une
sélection étrangère pendant l'euro la
ville de versailles à rénover le stade
de montbron coût total de l'opération
une centaine de milliers d'euros
on a aménagé une salle et sous les
tribunes que tu es un peu vieillotte
donc on a réaménagé de façon à ce qu'on
veut en faire une salle de presse donc
moi une salle de réception pour le club
bon à l'entraînement de presse et puis
des aménagements de vestiaire c'est pas
grand chose mais c'est important
ces dernières semaines la roumanie la
pologne la turquie les émissaires de
l'équipe d'italie aurait visité les
installations de versailles les
sélections devraient annoncer leur choix
avant la fin de l'année après le
football on passe à la boxe coup de
projecteur sur le sportif marie aphatie
un événement à ne pas manquer pour les
amateurs de boxe l'élan courtois marvin
petit 24 ans 16 victoires dont 8 par ko
pour une seule défaite dans sa carrière
affronte ce samedi à levallois
sylvain perret chapelle de pour le
championnat de france léger pour nous
parler de son rendez-vous nous recevons
le boxeur marvin petit son entraîneur
temps guy farrugia bonsoir alors marvin
ne nous sommes à quelques jours de
l'événement
la question est simple est-ce que vous
êtes prêts et là je suis bien prêt ouais
j'ai fait une bonne préparation
maintenant j'attends j'attends que
samedi je suis impatient de monter sur
le ring beau temps dit est ce qu'il est
dans sa forme optimale vite et bien et
bien c'est à dire il va ramener la
ceinture
il est bien à la maintenant il ya encore
des n'est pas champion du monde on sait
qu'un chat s'échapper en france à savoir
qu'on a des beaucoup d'objectifs dans le
futur avec son sponsor qui est la marque
airness et donc je pense qu'il va
ramener la ceinture et tout de suite
après le championnat d'europe et est ce
que vous êtes travailler peut-être
certains aspects dans la boxe de marvin
peut-être petit quelques petits défauts
qu'il fallait corriger par rapport au
dernier combat à je vois que ça fait
sourire marvin martin est ce que vous
avez c'est un peu dur web a nagé de
travailler dur j'ai fait ce qu'il
fallait que ça fait des pays c'est le
temps que je me prépare ça fait trois
mois que j'ai fait tout ce qu'il fallait
je me sente année dure il est temps
qu'ils étaient derrière moi j'ai fait
tout ce que nous tous que le disais ça a
été très dur pendant pendant trois mois
j'ai souffert mais je vais emmener ses
cinq jours c'est peut-être la première
fois vous souffre autant dans un
entraînement mais là j'ai à dire j'ai
pas mal souffert la c
j'ai passé des souffrances que j'ai même
passé en fait d'un guide il dit vrai
village et padoue dire parce que là des
choses qu'on a fait une bonne
préparation physique technique et il a
mis les gants avec les meilleurs
nationaux
quelques-uns qui sont mondiaux on a été
obligé de là il est parti en belgique en
belgique à s'entraîner et en italie
s'entraîner avec un ex champion d'europe
est un qui est classée en belgique avec
un qui est classée mondiale voilà on a
eu les meilleures se parler une
meilleure condition
maintenant il faut il faut confirmer la
victoire et est ce que vous avez je sais
pas confiné peut-être une technique en
particulière ça fait à l'instinct vivent
peut-être une technique de frappe tout à
fait ça on ne dit pas parce que je sais
que l'adversaire veut avoir en lui
donnera la surprise la surprise ce sera
samedi
voilà en tout cas je sais que il prendra
pas beaucoup de coups ce jour sylvain
chapelle c'est un adversaire que vous
connaissez bien omar bin vous l'avez
déjà mais j'ai googlé bien oui j'ai déjà
affronté à ça fait ça fait deux ans tous
deux ans et demi à peu fait cher la
finale de la coupe de la ligue
si vous l'aviez là dessus et je l'avais
battu mais bon comme on dit ils n'auront
jamais pareil lui il s'est entraîné dur
il entraînait pour ça et là elles
entraîné pour une à chercher la ceinture
mais il n'a cherché à s'enfuir va
falloir qu'ils se lavent footballeur et
donc donc vous connaissez bien ou aussi
tanguy qu'elles sont quelles sont les
recettes pour remporter la victoire ce
combat leur set comme je dis je dirais
pas mais disons que c'est un adversaire
qui est dur il ya toujours des cas
beaucoup de défaites mais qu'il ya
toujours des adversaires chez
l'adversaire qui ne recule jamais et
il a donc des défaites toujours
contestable donc c'est toujours des
décotes desserrer on donne toujours des
points d'avancé mais jamais assez pour
qu'on est chez l'adversaire
donc on s'est préparé une technique
exprès pour pour lui faire une surprise
et peut-être une belle surprise
on espère la victoire dans les années 80
et est ce que c'est un adversaire
difficile pour marvin ou est-ce qu'il
est largement à sa portée
marvin c'est le grand favori il rentre à
maurice le grand favori voilà que jeudi
a beaucoup d'avenir
marvin lo chih là à 30 ans marvin à 24
ans tous de l'avenir et pour marvin donc
il faut mais il faut pas échouer là
c'est sûr et comment gères sur justement
marine quand on sait qu'on est favori
d'un combat est ce qu'on le prépare
différemment ce qu'on va après voilà moi
je fais dans ma tête je pense pas que
ses favoris je pense que je viens d pour
la victoire
je vais aller pour gagner quoi je vais
pas me dire dans ma tête oui je suis
plus fort que lui ça ça veut rien dire
on arrivait solo ring le combat sera pas
le même
donc moi je suis prêt pour faire un
combat à la guerre si la guillaume jeu
redire ou me faire un et puis il ya un
aspect aussi qu'il faudra pas négliger
tanguy aussi c'est la taille
marvin mesure 5 cm de plus que son
adversaire que sylvain chapelle est ce
que ça joue dans un combat oui donc il
faut savoir s'en servir
savoir se servir de savoir s'en servir
je vous donne un rideau de tyson qui est
tout petit pour un poids lourd et qui
gagnait beaucoup qu'il y en ait
quasiment tous ses combats
voilà il faut savoir s'en servir
maintenant je pense qu'on s'est préparé
pour que marvin
se servent des cinq sont innocents
est-ce qu'il faudra aussi trouver la
longe peut-être au niveau du bras marvin
mais après la chute comme éditoriaux je
suis moi je suis prêt pour en faire un
combat de guerrier et donc j'ai cinq
centimes de plus que lui donc je peux je
pourrais donner les coups que je veux
c'est un avantage sur vous c'est ou
c'était d'affaires d'inconvénients c'est
plus un avantage d'avoir une peau
blanche que l'adversaire parce que tout
tient à distance tu peux faire la guerre
avec lui
donc après voilà c'est je suis je suis
prêt pour pousser dire ou mme donc je
pense qu'il y aura pas de soucis au
niveau au bras de tenir physiquement
tout est impeccable quoi alors mine
je lui ai dit tout à l'heure vous avez
fait 8 ko sur c'est ce qu'on va mais un
un peu plus voilà mais sur les seize
victoires en tout cas vous avez mis 8 ko
est ce que là encore vous allez chercher
le ko tout de suite
ou est-ce que vous allez être patient
mais je serais moi je veux pas chercher
le cas où le chaos façon ça vient tout
seul c'est bien sûr le sauvait sur un
coup donc moi je vais chercher à boxer
je sais que j'ai les dix roulent dans le
monde
donc j'ai cherché à boxer et je vais
chercher à lever sans difficulté et
chinois le trouve je voulais mettre
beaucoup quoi on s il faut être patient
sentant son adversaire jamais été battu
avant la limite
voilà moi je pense que marvin a toutes
ses chances de gagner avant la limite ce
combat là mais c'est sûr il va pas
falloir qu'il se produit ce qui se
précipite on a sécurisé un combat qui va
se passer dans le giron
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure il ya
aussi lâches qui va qui va rentrer en
compte dans ce combat il a 30 ans oui
marvin en 1 24
est-ce que aussi ça peut ça peut jouer
dans dans l'expérience du combat est ce
que justement il va peut être essayer de
faire courir un petit peu à marvin le
fatiguer pour essayer de contrer au
dernier moment non
c'est quelqu'un qui va qui va passer à
vers tes jambes qui va aller à la guerre
on c'est sa dernière chance ou une de
ses dernières chances il vient
d'apprendre va tout faire pour la gagner
donc nous on sait on s'est préparé pour
le propulser cette chanson et ses titres
de champion de france il représente quoi
pour vous à mardi ça représente beaucoup
1 c'est quelque chose qui vous toutes
les portes quoi c'est là tu perds donc
tu obligé d'attendre encore un an et
demi deux ans donc c'est possible c'est
pas intéressant quoi c'est un match
crucial pour rien là et c'est très
important que la chine vienne là je peux
tout six derniers jeux par l opportunité
de faire le show pas d'europe
donc voila quoi on se sort encore une
fois derrière et tout le monde n'a pas
la chance d'avoir ça et on en sort on
remercie le mali ne connaît et toute son
équipe de nous organiser sa jeunesse
avant de se quitter et marvin on regarde
deux interviews réalisées cette semaine
au palais des sports d'el en cours en
vue ne dirais pas que la peur froid aux
yeux qui le courage de tous on le sait
très bien mais ce que j'aime bien sur
les skis me rappelle les boxeurs à
l'ancienne un petit peu il a un style
old school
j'apprécie je le respecte en tant que
boxeur surtout principalement voilà ça
porte à marvin c'est sa capacité à ne
jamais lâcher parce que c'est un très
très grand compétiteur et il va sur le
ring pour la gagne et rien d'autre à des
fêtes elle n'existe pas
harbin ces compliments et vous touche a
cédé très bon complément j'ai remercié
lui deux collègues de la boxe et donc on
va tout faire samedi pour en est cité
pour les sites à turin merci en tout cas
à tous les deux passés sur son plateau
bon courage pour votre combat de ce
samedi donc à levallois est-ce que vous
avez un message à faire passer à votre
adversaire
marvin j'ai un bon message j'espère
qu'il est prêt parce que mentalement je
vais lui faire je voulais faire une
guerre comme l'achat comme n'a jamais eu
quoi je suis fier vraiment mal quoi vous
allez faire mal
je veux lui faire vraiment vraiment très
bons jeunes merci beaucoup marvin
j'espère que le message est passé on
passe à présent au tennis de table
tennis de table le championnat
départemental des vétérans étaient
programmés ce mercredi au gymnase
thierry gilardi aux clayes-sous-bois une
centaine de participants âgés de 40 à
plus de 70 ans a participé à la
compétition
williams elle pour les images
la passion pour le tennis de table n'a
pas d'âge pour la deuxième année
consécutive le championnat départemental
des vétérans une catégorie pour les
joueurs âgés de 40 à 70 ans était
organisé au gymnase thierry gilardi
sous bois objectif de cette
compétition déterminer le classement des
yvelines et meilleurs sont qualifiés
pour le championnat régional
le tennis de table est un sport qui
vieillit un poil dire donc à plus en
plus de vétérans mais des vétérans qui
joue depuis déjà un bon moment au niveau
de la pratique de ce sport et le niveau
1 reste assez intéressant puisque les
meilleurs vont se qualifier pour le
niveau régional et après le niveau
national au total 116 participants venus
de 23 clubs du département ont participé
à la compétition pour remporter la
victoire chaque joueur a sa technique
je joue emprise porte plume
comme un certain nombre de chinois c'est
à dire que je tiens ma raquette avec
deux doigts
c'est un peuple c'est un petit peu
particulier parce que le jeu est très
axé sur le coup droit après
effectivement chaque personne a son
propre jeu il ya des attaquants et les
défenseurs et à l'intérieur des
attaquants et les défenseurs il ya aussi
des spécificités quoi c'est plutôt un
poussette et le contre
voilà un peu le revers mais on dit
qu'avec mon robert vous avez vu la
finale on a surtout beaucoup poussé ont
assez de se neutraliser donc voilà en
jeu c'est un peut décider d'embêter
d'adversaires plus que de marquer des
points en attaquant rapport plusieurs
techniques mais l'objectif reste la
victoire sept joueurs sont montés sur la
plus haute marche du podium dans leur
catégorie respective
chez les hommes le gluant courtois
pascal pièce et a brillé pendant la
compétition
le pongiste a raflé la mise dans la
catégorie des 50 59 ans coup de
projecteur à présent sur une discipline
méconnue le tir subaquatique le club de
plaisir la palme plaisir oise qui
s'entraînent à la piscine salvador
allende clayes-sous-bois fait partie des
meilleurs clubs de l'hexagone et compte
plusieurs champions de france pour nous
parler de ce club nous recevons sur ce
plateau
vanessa bentobal coach fédéral n'est ni
à un pied est championne de france 2015
junior françois-xavier père n'est membre
de l'équipe de france est alexa guillot
championne de france 2015 cadette
bonsoir alors vanessa tout d'abord voilà
est-ce que vous vous présentez cette
discipline pour les téléspectateurs qui
ne connaîtraient pas le tir subaquatique
c'est une discipline qui se déroule en
apnée avec différentes épreuves ya une
épreuve de précision qui consiste à
faire 10 tirs en dix minutes
relativement cool
il ya une deux épreuves de vitesse une
qui s'appelle le biathlon qui consiste à
allier vitesse et précision et une autre
qui s'appelle le super biathlon qui se
rapproche un petit peu du biathlon
nordique avec de la vitesse mais un
contrat cible plutôt qu'un score cible
françois xavier
quelle île à l'épreuve la plus
compliquée selon vous
je subis un groupe super biathlon
simplement parce qu'on a cinq tirs
maximum à réaliser dans cinq visuels
une fois passée la période des
qualifications
il ya une ambiance de vitesse jusqu'à
que la vitesse qui est pris en compte
dans cette dans cette discipline dans
cette épreuve par deux et donc c'est une
discipline qui dérivés de la chasse sous
marine
on peut dire ça un petit peu on peut
dire ça oui comme on a déjà pu
l'expliquer auparavant les chasseurs
utiliser ces les piscines est donc cette
discipline pour garder
pendant la période hivernale le leurs
compétences pour reprendre facilement
pour retour à la rentrée dans l'eau dans
la merde ça est ce que c'est une
discipline physique c'est voilà les
grands seigneurs sens où forcément mais
est-ce que c'est aussi physique wilson
et ses preuves de vitesse forcément il
faut aller vite donc il faut les bonnes
cuisses pour avancer efficacement dans
l'eau donc il ya beaucoup de technique à
acquérir pour pour gagner en vitesse
parce que ben au niveau ça se joue sur
quelques secondes donc sur la technique
qu'on peut gagner dans mais combien de
temps pour devenir un bon un bon enfin
quelqu'un qui fait voilà du tir et se
bâtit comment comment comment on fait
pour pour devenir bon dans cette
discipline
on s'entraîne et puis surtout au niveau
de l'oeil c'est surtout au niveau de la
cne au niveau de la technique de nage et
au niveau du tir parce que forcément
pour les épreuves de biathlon un plaisir
on est assez spécialisés en biathlon et
donc si c'est vraiment la discipline
phare pour nous parce que c'est vitesse
et précision
donc si on s'entraîne pas en précision
peut pas obtenir les points essentiels
pour pour le score final donc il faut il
faut s'entraîner sur tous les plans
françois xavier est ce que vous sentez
qu'il ya un engouement autour de ce
sport est ce qu on en parle de plus en
plus c'est ce que vous sentez vous
est-ce que ça reste encore un petit peu
difficile mais également dans d'autres
pays je pense ça se passe mieux
notamment grèce en russie
donc on essaye de faire le plus de
publicité publicité possible notamment
grâce à un clip qu'on a réalisé il ya
deux ans aujourd'hui
qui a bien fonctionné ça a permis de
faire connaître davantage cette
discipline même au sein de la fédération
puisqu'on compte notamment la najac pam
la nage en eau vive la plongée donc même
pour eux c'est important qu'ils
connaissent toutes les disciplines de
notre fédération et vous n'ayez à
liliane pied vous avez débuté à la
discipline y a trois ans pourquoi vous
êtes lancés dans cette dans cette
discipline qu'est ce qui vous a donné
envie de goûter aux tirs sur les
pratiques mais en fait tout simplement
je faisais de la plongée avant et il
fallait que je fasse mon niveau 1
et pour ça il fallait que j'attende donc
on m'a proposé d'essayer tir et bages et
direct accroché samassa m'a plu et du
coup j'ai continué entre les personnes
vous en a parlé avant de commencer ça ça
fait comment ben on m'a proposé
justement de l'ordre de faire une
initiation et c'est là que je l' ai
découvert avec ça
oui j'ai commencé la plongée et j'ai
passé mon niveau 1 est effectivement
pour attendre pour passer mon niveau 2
bat pour passer le temps et pour rester
dans l'eau j'ai décidé fin j'ai pratiqué
un baptême de tir et ça m'a beaucoup plu
on entendait beaucoup parler enfin rien
qu'au sein du club des compétitions
réalisé des scores réalisés aussi et du
courage mais je suis inscrite et
généralement quand vous dites à vos amis
que vous faites du tir subaquatique
quelle est la réaction
nous regardons nous demandons tout
simplement qu est-ce que c'est déjà
parce qu'ils réalisent pas en fait que
c'est pas très faim qu'on s'est pas pour
eux c'est pas imaginable qu'on puisse
réaliser quelques chemins un sport pas
connu et là quand on sort un peu du fin
de l'ordinaire nous demande qu'est ce
que c'était tout simplement et dans ce
cas là on leur explique la discipline et
le club de plaisir du coup on enregistre
de très bons résultats
c'est leur année pourquoi qu'est ce qui
fait qu est ce qui fait la force de ce
club
l'apam plaisir oise pour vos besoins le
club le club le club il est exceptionnel
en fait on a
un staff merveilleux en fait on a un
président et tout son bureau qui
soutiennent chacune des disciplines que
ce soit à la plongée la plongée enfin la
nage en eau vive
l'apnée le tir tous les moyens sont
donnés à chacune des commissions pour
pouvoir bien s'exprimer même la biologie
on a quelqu'un qui est très fort en
biologie et donc chaque discipline va
s'intéresser à une autre au sein du club
donc en fait on est très solidaire très
soudée et donc si on a envie de
développer une discipline car on a le
soutien derrière
donc là on allait on a tout ce qu'il
nous faut pour bien nous exprimer mais
moi bien avoir un peu plus de lignes
d'eau mais il faut partager
donc voilà françois-xavier vous avez 28
ans l'actuel m'en voyez qu'il ya des
petites jeunes comme les lianes pied qui
pousse est-ce que c'est aussi ça la
force de finalement de plaisir de la
plaine plaisir oise de renouveler les
talents tout simplement
bien sûr oui c'est toujours important de
faire découvrir la discipline notamment
à des jeunes
ça nous faisait également dans des
démarches publicitaires mais pour pour
faire vivre et continue à faire vivre
cette discipline il faut que les jeunes
s'intéressent à tyr subaquatique et dans
à rennes ça fonctionne et notamment il
ajouté
spécialement pour les jeunes en fête des
écoles de tir subaquatique à vire
également donc pourquoi pas faire la
même chose ici
nelly vous qu'est ce qui vous pousse en
fait voilà à continuer dans dans ce club
vous avez gagné de nombreux titres vous
n'avez pas envie de partir du tout
assurément non
bien sûr va je j'ai envie de continuer à
tout simplement parce que j'adore ce
sport je me sens bien dans l'eau et puis
voilà surtout parce que y'a l'entourage
et à l'équipe il ya toujours une super
ambiance
et puis je trouve ça apporte beaucoup
humainement et on en apprend aussi sur
soi même et est ce que tout le monde
peut venir tester tir subaquatique à la
peine que les 0 à 6 ans encore des
places on peut s'inscrire c'est complet
c'est complet quand j'utilisais on
aimerait bien avoir plus de lignes d'eau
pour pour accueillir plus de monde on a
dû en refuser cette année et
par contre on fait des initiations
régulièrement donc en fait aussi des
compétitions vous organiser des
compétitions va justement à l'écran le
trophée nathalie 500 ce qui nous tient à
coeur parce que c'était quelqu'un
d'important pour nous au club donc on
lui dédie ce trophée
elle était arbitre national tout ça nous
a quittés prématurément donc on lui rend
hommage avec une très belle compétition
donc elle aura lieu fin janvier merci à
vous d'être passé sur ce plateau vous
souhaite bonne continuation et on va
suivre avec attention ce trophée en
passe maintenant aux autres résultats du
week end
on commence cette rubrique résultats par
la 12e édition de la transat jacques
vabre vous le savez le skipper
versaillais tanguy de lamotte a
participé à la compétition cette année
le navigateur est parti avec sa
coéquipière samantha davies le dimanche
25 octobre du port du havre à bord de
son imoca initiative coeur après 18
jours de course le skipper et sa
coéquipière sont arrivés ils ont terminé
leur périple de dix mille kilomètres
jeudi dernier à la cinquième place du
classement
on écoute tanguy de lamotte il a adressé
une vidéo juste après l'arrivée
visiblement le soleil est au rendez vous
au brésil c'était royal royal super
content d'être là dur de vie être
justement donc c'est pour ça qu'on est
super content
jusqu'au bout on ya cru jusqu'au bout on
s'est battu le duo a vachement bien
fonctionné l'équipe avec sam a été
génial et et on a battu on a été au
dessus des objectifs qu'on s'était fixés
quoi pour ce qui est des objectifs
solidaire ban a atteint 20 enfants ce
qui était le double de ce qu'on avait
fixé au départ donc voilà ça c'est top
la traversée de tanguy de lamotte aborde
son imoca ni steve carr a permis de
récolter assez d'argent pour sauver 20
enfants souffrant d'une maladie
cardiovasculaire ce sera l'un des
événements ne pas manquer ce week-end à
saint quentin en yvelines les
championnats de france de judo au sud
junior sont programmées au vélodrome
nationale et combats débuteront à 8h30
le samedi à 9 heures le dimanche de
compétitions seront organisées la coupe
de france individuels et les
championnats par équipes de club
au total plus de 900 combattants sont
attendus pour ce rendez vous si vous
voulez assister à la compétition il
reste des places à la vente sur le site
internet du vélo tome national de saint
quentin en yvelines
ce magazine touche à sa fin le jeu vous
rappelle la principale information de ce
sept huit sports les manifestations
sportives dans les yvelines ont été
annulés ce week-end suite aux attentats
de paris qui ont fait 129 morts et des
centaines de blessés vendredi soir à
saint quentin en yvelines les
handballeuses de montier bretons mais
les basketteurs de trappes ont vu leur
match déplacé en football le match de
coupe de france entre versailles et
blanc mini leurs portes à une date
ultérieure le sport devrait reprendre
ses droits ce week-end dans les yvelines
c'est la fin de cette fuite sport merci
d'avoir suivi je vous retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau magazine très
belle soirée sur tv fil 78